I also talked about run brooder I
thought I would share a story where I
learned something else that's not in the
book so Ron I met Ron and I got to write
about him and he became a very very
close friend and he also became one of
my mentors he's a remarkable human being
and it was from Ron that I actually
learned more about what mentorship
really means you know I get emails from
people that say you know will you be my
mentor and the answer's no I won't for
the same reason that if you sent me an
email it just said will you be my friend
yeah but like I don't even know you like
we can't do that you can't go up to we
can't go up to strangers and say will
you be my friend it's a little weird
right and this is what I started to
learn about mentorship it's exactly the
same as French friendship I didn't ask
Rondon to be my mentor like a friend it
evolved and and what I learned as a
mentor is someone who always has time
for you after I met run I remember I
wanted his advice on something and I
called him up and this was before start
with white took off before there was a
TED talk and there was no start with why
because I was still interviewing Ron and
I remember calling him up and I wanted
his advice and he took my call he's a
very successful guy and he took my call
and he gave me earnest advice and I
remember some weeks later I called him
again and he took my call again he kept
making time for me and eventually what
happened is a friendship evolved and I
remember I was at his house once this is
well into our friendship and I was
getting ready to leave and I put my arm
around him as I was getting ready to say
goodbye and I said you know Ron I love
that you're my mentor and he looked back
and said something to me that I didn't
expect he said and I love that you're
mine now
this is when I realized that mentor
relationships aren't mentor mentee it's
not like it's not just teacher-student
but it's rather mentor mentor that
sometimes I didn't realize that though I
was coming to him for advice that he was
learning from me - just like friendship
sometimes we're the givers and our
friends in our friendships sometimes
we're the receivers in our friendships
it's it's it's this beautiful it's this
beautiful thing so mentor relationships
are not like champions you know you have
someone at your company who's your
champion you expect them to like put
your name forward for a promotion
mentors don't get involved in you're in
your career there just there and they
believe in you so thanks to Ron brooder
I learned a lot more about what
mentorship means and it's really much
more like a loving friendship
[Music]
you